foreign
are you looking to supercharge your
data-driven applications with new
generative AI capabilities like Google
Palm 2
we're going to walk you through step by
step how you can build new AI powered
applications in Google Cloud using
postgres databases that you already love
and rely on
we will show you how you can integrate
the postgres extension PG Vector with
Lang chain and large language models
Vector embeddings are a way of
representing data that makes it easy to
search for the most similar or relevant
data using approximate nearest neighbor
search algorithms this fundamental
technology can not only power user
experiences like product recommendations
or in-application searches but it's also
a critical primitive and more advanced
machine learning use cases like
simulating long-term memory for llms
Vector embeddings are used in many AI
applications including some of Google
services like Google photos Google lens
and YouTube you can learn more about the
vector embeddings in the description
link below
Cloud SQL for postgres and lab for
postgres both support the PG Vector
extension which enables storing and
querying Vector embeddings in your
postgres database
this allows you to easily build AI
enabled experiences in your applications
on top of your real-time operational
data
we're going to dive into a notebook that
will guide you through creating an AI
powered app using PG Vector after
completing all the steps you'll have a
good understanding of how to use the PG
Vector extension you're also going to
get a Hands-On view of using the lane
chain open source framework to develop
applications powered by llms and finally
you'll learn about Google Cloud's
powerful Palm models that we make
available through vertex AI
this notebook uses an example of an
e-commerce company that runs an online
Marketplace for buying and selling
children's toys
the team wants to add new generative AI
experiences in their e-commerce
applications for both buyers and sellers
for buyers we want to build a new AI
powered hybrid search where users can
describe their needs in simple text as
well as applying filters on things like
price
for sellers we want to add a new AI
powered content generation feature where
they'll get auto-generated description
suggestions for new products that they
want to sell
the data set for this notebook has about
800 toy products and is sampled and
created from a larger public retail data
set available at kaggle.com
we've already done all the pre-work of
installing the required packages into
our notebook setting up our Google Cloud
environment so we can jump right into
the good parts you can still see all the
setup instructions in the notebook
though
stepping into the notebook now we
download the data set from a web URL and
stored into a pandas data frame
you can see the first 10 rows of the
pandas data frame as an example of the
data we will load into our postgres
table
the next step is to save this pandas
data frame in our postgres table
we first create a table called products
and then copy the pandas data frame into
the table
next we'll generate Vector embeddings
using a text embedding model
the first step to do that is to split
long product description text into
smaller chunks we need to split large
descriptions into chunks so they can fit
in a single API request we use the
character text Splitter from the
langchain library to split the
description into chunks of 500
characters each
the next step is to generate a vector
embedding for each chunk by calling an
embedded generation service we're using
the vertex AI text embedding model which
outputs a 768 dimensional Vector for
each chunk
we have loaded the generated Vector
embeddings into a data frame and you can
see the first five rows here
next is to use the PG Vector extension
for storing the generated embeddings in
the postgres database the PG Vector
extension introduces a new Vector data
type which allows us to directly save a
vector embedding through a simple insert
statement in postgres
to do this first we create the extension
in the database
then we create a table called product
embeddings that has a column of type
vector
using an insert statement we can store
this Vector directly into the postgres
table
now we've extracted the semantic
knowledge of our product database and
stored it into a vector table using the
PG Vector extension
now we can show you how you use the
semantic knowledge to answer complex
natural language queries from users for
our first use case we want to build an
AI curated hybrid contextual search that
combines the natural language text with
regular relational filters
for example a grandparent wants to use
the AI powered search to find an
educational toy for their grandkid that
fits their budget they may enter a query
like I want to buy a fun toy for my
grandkid that teaches new skills
your application could also add
additional filters based on operational
data like price or real-time inventory
to improve results the first step is to
generate the vector embeddings for that
user query
here we call the embeddings model from
the application and the next step is to
use the PG Vector extension to find
similar products
we use the similarity search operator
from the PG Vector extension to find
product vectors that are closer in
distance to the user query additionally
we also specify regular query filters on
price in the same SQL query
by using PG Vector we can now integrate
the power of relational databases with
Vector search operations after running
the code snippet we found a product that
closely matches our user query
after finding similar products and their
descriptions using PG Vector we will use
this context to generate an informative
response from a large language model for
the user query
individual product descriptions can be
long and may not fit within the input
prompt limit for an llm model so we use
the mapreduce chain from the langchain
framework to generate and combine short
summaries of similarly matched products
the combined summaries are then used to
build a high quality prompt for an input
in the llm model
for our prompt we instruct the llm to
include the name price and features of
every toy in the summary and then we
instruct the llm to answer the user
query using the combined summaries we
can even have the llm output the answer
in markdown format with features listed
as bullet points let's go ahead and run
this now
there we have our answer fully formatted
for our Second Use case we want to add
creative content generation that uses
Knowledge from our existing data set for
example a seller on the retail platform
wants to use the AI powered content
generation to create a detailed
description of their new product they
can enter a new product description in a
few words like a bicycle with brand name
Roadstar bike for kids that comes with
training wheels and helmet like the
first use case we will use the PG Vector
similarity search operator to find an
existing product description that
closely matches our new product
we will use this existing product
description as a creative prompt to our
llm model for generating a new detailed
description
Amazing by leveraging the power of llms
we can generate a detailed description
of an entirely new product using our
existing knowledge of bicycle products
and that's it if you aren't going to
keep tinkering don't forget to delete
your database instance
we showed you just two examples of
powerful features that you can create by
combining llms and databases
generative AI is a powerful paradigm
shift in application development we're
excited to see what you build
find a link to the collab we use today
in the description below thanks for
watching
[Music]